nous avons commencé à étudier le texte
en séance dès le jeudi 20 octobre
et après aussi pudeur de débat en
hémicycle alors que les discussions
avancées bien alors que nous proposions
en masse des alternatives qui
répondaient aux exigences et aux besoins
de nos concitoyens de France hexagonale
et de France d'outre-mer vous avez
engagé et réengagé par la suite avec
légèreté et sourire en toute confiance
la responsabilité de votre gouvernement
vous avez dit madame la Première
ministre que le texte avait été débattu
et voté en commission comme si la
démocratie se jouait avec quelques un
seul mot
cela nous rappelle un certain conseil de
défense sanitaire
nous savons tous comment vous
fonctionner sous forme de conseils
d'administration mais la République
française n'est pas une entreprise et ce
ne sera jamais plus un régime absolu
[Applaudissements]
faut-il vous rappeler et je le répète
pour Emmanuel Macron qui a du oublier
ses cours de droit constitutionnels
qu'il y a 577 députés ici présents à
pouvoir voter sur les textes
je le dis aux Français qui nous
regardent
l'État ont changé
l'armée de clones Playmobil de votre
gouvernement autoritaire a été battue
aux dernières élections
l'Assemblée nationale est aujourd'hui
notamment avec la nupesse
issue d'une diversité que les Français
souhaitent et pour qui ils ont voté en
juin dernier contre votre politique et
celle du président de la République
vendredi soir toujours vous avez dit que
nous réouvrions nous réouvrions des
débats inutiles que de la commission
avec les 500 les 650 amendements déposés
sur environ 80 articles
mais madame nous n'avions pas de 49,3
jeudi dernier alors que mon camarade
aimerait Caron a été obligé de retirer
le texte pour l'abolition de la corrida
après avoir reçu 766 amendements sur un
seul et unique l'article
nous n'avions pas de 49,3 jeudi dernier
pour augmenter le SMIC à 1600 euros ou
pour en finir avec le débat sur la
réintégration des personnels des
établissements de santé et de secours
non vacciné
vous entendre vous lamenter sur le
nombre d'amendements avoué que cela est
un peu croquignolesque certes il y a des
avancées dans ce texte comme les
rendez-vous de prévention la gratuité
des dépistages ist pour les moins de 26
ans la pilule du lendemain gratuite et
sans ordonnance pour toutes un contrôle
renforcé dans les EHPAD et l'encadrement
des fixations des prix des médicaments
et notamment des thérapies géniques
mais d'une part c'est très insuffisant
en termes de progrès social et d'autre
part il n'y a aucune conciliation dans
ce texte aucune de nos avancées sociales
majeures n'ont été retenues aucun des
compromis votés au sein de cette
émission n'ont été conservées alors
qu'il y a urgence dans le pays à
réformer et donner des moyens
supplémentaires à l'ensemble des
branches de la sécurité sociale
notamment à la branche autonomie grande
oubliée qu'il n'a jamais véritablement
eu les moyens à la hauteur de ses
besoins
les logiques de marché font encore de la
démons encore la démonstration de leur
incapacité à produire autre chose que le
chaos et les pénuries
c'est ainsi que le CHU de Nantes est en
grève depuis plus d'un mois et que vous
n'avez prévu aucun stock d'amoxicilline
et de paracétamol
deux des médicaments les plus prescrits
en France
n'entendez-vous pas les appels à l'aide
de la petite enfance et de la protection
de l'enfance qui hurle d'un abandon
l'âge de l'état
ouvrez les yeux sur le monde que vous
êtes en train de créer pour lequel vous
n'avez rien planifié un quart des plus
pauvres seront déjà morts à 62 ans la
France n'est plus qu'un désert médical
ou se soigner est devenu un luxe pour
beaucoup
votre budget est par définition austère
et n'a pour seul but de faire toujours
plus économie sur le dos des plus
pauvres et des plus précaires ce pour
qui la vie n'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille
mes chers collègues de l'opposition
républicains liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire horizons et même
démocrate il est il est grand temps de
montrer que vous êtes indépendant
respectable et que vous êtes ici pour
faire entendre votre voix et non pour
vous taire
vous avez eu la preuve criante que ce
gouvernement borné essaye tout
simplement de tuer la démocratie à petit
feu qu'il tente par tous les moyens de
museler la volonté du peuple
l'Assemblée nationale es-tu sous couvert
d'une constitution vieillissante les
médias sont censurés les manifestations
réprimées avec une volonté croissante de
les empêcher
je n'ai jamais eu aussi peur pour ma
démocratie pour la liberté d'expression
ou pour ma France chers collègues il est
temps de vous rappeler et de rappeler à
l'ordre ce gouvernement quant aux
limites de ses pouvoirs
nous savons que ces discussions ne sont
que des farces et que les sourires
confiants perpétuels de la première
ministre lorsqu'elle engage la
responsabilité de son gouvernement acte
hautement grave et solennel ne sont que
les provocations et leur accumulation ne
sert qu'à endormir la vigilance des
Français et de leur représentants
il n'est pas sérieux de parler de
brutalité pour l'utilisation d'un outil
constitutionnel pour lequel un
gouvernement engage sa responsabilité
devant des oppositions numériquement
plus nombreuses
et il est méprisant pour vos collègues
ce que vous appelez avec élégance des
clones ou des Playmobil alors que ce
sont comme vous ni moins ni plus que
vous des élus du peuple des députés de
la nation
il est méprisant d'occulter le débat
parlementaire alors que le texte a pu
être discuté et adopté par deux fois en
commission qu'il a été examiné au Sénat
qu'il a été enrichi grâce au députés
comme au sénateur et que vous êtes allé
au terme des outils constitutionnels à
votre disposition en déposant
systématiquement d'émotions de censure
dans votre motion de censure
vous prenez le soin de ne pas rappeler
que si cette quatrième partie du texte
était censurée ce sont les piliers de
notre politique sociale qui tomberait
c'est l'hôpital c'est l'autonomie c'est
le handicap ce sont les prestations
sociales qui seraient privés de moyens
vous oubliez de rappeler que votre
censure s'oppose à des mesures que vous
soutenez-vous même comme la gratuité de
la contraception d'urgence pour les
jeunes femmes vous faites semblant
d'oublier aussi que votre motion de
censure met en péril des avancées
nouvelles fruits du débat parlementaire
lui-même je pense au contenu des
rendez-vous de prévention que les
parlementaires ont enrichi je pense à
une meilleure organisation entre les
professionnels de santé je pense aux
sanctions renforcées contre les EHPAD
qui ne respectent pas les demandes des
autorités de contrôle je pense encore au
remboursement intégral des prothèses
capillaires pour les patientes atteintes
de cancer ça aussi votre motion de
censure en privé nos compatriotes
le problème mesdames et messieurs les
députés de la France insoumise c'est que
les faits sont têtus quand on les tort
ils vous reviennent en boomerang et
votre censure une fois de plus et pavé
de contradiction vous affirmez qu'il n'y
a pas de hausse des ressources affectées
à la santé et vous reconnaissez ensuite
quels augmentent massivement depuis 2019
avant la pandémie les moyens de la santé
ont augmenté de 43 milliards d'euros
voilà ce qu'il serait honnête de
reconnaître et de dire la liste est
longue car elle avait été ce budget de
la Sécurité sociale et protecteur il
répond au défi de la situation et il
correspond au programme qu'on choisit
les Français
mesdames et messieurs les députés de la
France insoumise c'est manœuvres
n'apportent rien à la démocratie elle
n'apporte rien au débat
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
sécurité sociale est un des biens les
plus précieux de notre pays elle est le
fruit d'année de lutte et de progrès
elle est synonyme d'égalité et de
liberté la sécurité sociale et la santé
de nos concitoyens méritent mieux que
des postures et des outrances elle
mérite mieux que les excès et les débats
rendus stérile à force de contre vérité
je l'ai dit à cette tribune plusieurs
fois je le répéterai et j'en ferai la
démonstration autant de fois qu'il le
faudra je suis prête au compromis et
avec mon gouvernement nous y sommes
résolus mais le compromis ne peut se
bâtir que deux bonnes foi il ne peut
être trouvé que si chacun soit aboutir à
un accord gardons collectivement
majorité comme opposition l'esprit
ouvert et la volonté d'aboutir sur le
pouvoir d'achat pour la sécurité des
Français ou pour protéger le droit à
l'avortement nous avons montré que nous
en étions capables sur tous les textes
j'en suis convaincu nous ne pouvons je
vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre
la discussion est close
je vais maintenant mettre au voile la
motion de censure le scrutin est annoncé
dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
je rappelle que seuls les députés
favorables à la motion de censure
participe au scrutin et que le vote se
déroule dans les sales voisines de
l'hémicycle le scrutin va être ouvert
pour une durée de 30 minutes il sera
donc l'eau à 19h35 la séance est
suspendue
donc la séance est reprise voici le
résultat du scrutin majorité requise
pour l'adoption de la motion de censure
sur la majorité absolue des membres
proposant l'assemblée 289 pour
l'adoption 93 la majorité requise
n'étant pas atteinte la motion de
censure n'est pas adoptée en conséquence
la quatrième partie et l'ensemble du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 sont
considérés comme adoptés en nouvelle
lecture